[Music]
i'm so grateful that you're allowing me
to just talk come on man
uh and i love what you did with this
thing i was watching all the you know
because i'm fearful too so i was
watching all the interviews that you've
done with bo and kevin and
man there's like a you you found a
you found a gap not a whole lot of
places a guy like me can come and talk
my true you know or bo talk his truth
and sit down with another cop i think is
phenomenal with you i'm not just kissing
your ass i think i think this is really
special i like how small it is also
anyway what do you got to say you i know
you do your little intros
there you gotta be not you gotta be
anything like that i think
i think the first thing i want to say is
from what you said as soon as you got
out of that car yeah can you lead me in
a prayer yeah
definitely about this conversation what
we're trying to achieve first off i'm
prepared to go every which way let's go
yeah we i mean i i think that it's my
duty now like i when i think about what
my life has become and what it is now
like what my purpose is now you know
i i i need to be useful
and when i look at this me too
environment there's not a whole lot of
dudes that are taking accountability you
know i [ __ ] up bad bad like crash and
burn type [ __ ] hurt a lot of people
and um
and i'm fully aware of that and i'm
gonna owe for the rest of my life
for the rest of my life
and i also don't have that feeling about
uh
the woman who's accused me all this [ __ ]
like i did in the beginning when it
first landed
i thought man um you know
there was thing i wanted to hit twitter
and be like look i got receipts this
that that but this but not that but this
but not that and the reality is
uh all of that [ __ ] is unimportant the
reality is that
she saved my [ __ ] life dude yeah so i
i uh she's like a like some kind of sage
or like a
i don't know she she's uh she's a um
a saint for me because had she not
intervened in my life and not
created the avenue for me to experience
ego death i'd either have a really
mediocre existence or i'd be dead and
full and
you know i had no love in my life i had
no purpose in my life my whole purpose
as you know was just craft
it was just i'm gonna be good at this
thing and that's all that i have the
only thing i care about in life
is
being a good actor and that's such a
vapid shallow existence
and three emotions that i toggle between
which was
i would feel
anxiety depression and excitement and i
thought excitement was joy and i thought
lack of depression was
serenity peace and i had no spiritual
life i had a a very
i was bankrupt spiritually i thought my
whole my whole spirituality was this
craft
because other than smoking weed and
drinking the only spiritual experience i
ever felt was on set
you know that's the only time my
perspective would shift and change and
it's the only time i ever felt useful
and so um
i'm on a spiritual growth path i'm on a
uh
an excavation i'm picking it up cleaning
it up putting it back you know i didn't
just hurt that woman
the kind of shame my wife has to walk
around with you know
the um the the pain that came to the the
people i was working with creatively
even i built this like
me and beau built like something really
special downtown and uh and all them
kids you know i just failed a lot of
people and so when i say i'm gonna oh
it's not just her i owe a lot of people
and
so the reason i wanted to do this and
the reason why i felt like celestial
mathematics when you hit me up was
it's not a lot of places i can go talk
period you know and um
i guess old me would have looked at this
like oh well this is an opportunity for
you to like
speak your piece but really the only
thing i want to do is like give dudes
who [ __ ] up hope absolutely yeah what
can what what what can this achieve who
can this touch victim perpetrator
someone lost someone who's trying to be
found yeah who on that path pain is an
adhesive bro if you've been through it
yeah you can connect to people period
and the story the first thing i just
think like look man i haven't seen you
in a long time
and
um i want to talk about that yeah the
first thing i just need to ask you man
is i need to ask you about your child
yeah i need to ask you about your baby
bro
yo man tell me about your baby i mean
she's uh she is the most dynamic spark
of life and most magical
um
it's a game changer doug you know like i
you would always talk about your kid and
i was like yeah i've had a dog as though
them like like as though these loves are
like
anywhere near what you experience when
you have a kid but um
this was all tied in too like it came at
a time when
you know me and my girl been in love for
a long time but i didn't really know it
you know i didn't really know what love
was to all this [ __ ] hit the fan and she
was still around
i thought
she was in love with me because of what
i could offer i didn't know that when i
had [ __ ] jackal [ __ ] all nothing to
offer she would still love me so i
didn't i didn't really know what love
was right that's one and out of this
like newfound discovery of real love in
my life
this kid you know and
uh
it um
[Music]
i'm not gonna pretend like i like i
haven't figured it all out it's such a
mystery you know i and i what scares you
what scares me is like enough nobody
tells you about the first three weeks
you know the first three weeks man i
remember changing the diaper yeah you
know i've been hanging out with monks
for nine months and i came out a
monastery and i'm you know i've been in
rehab for three months and i've been
working you know been outside for a
while and so i thought i had like things
dialed in like i could press the pause
button but when you're changing a diaper
and
you change it and then you put it back
on she shits again
and then you change it again and she
shits again and it's three in the
morning you ain't slept for four days
and you're on the third it's the third
iteration of [ __ ] and you're sitting
there at the table
and you change it one more time you say
to yourself if you [ __ ] one more time
i'm gonna jump out the [ __ ] window
like i'm done right and you're looking
at your kid and you're just thinking how
how am i gonna get through this and you
you put the fourth diaper on and she
doesn't [ __ ] it feels like a miracle it
feels like god is hugging you like i got
you bro so i i don't know if i'm
infusing a bunch of stuff but there's
some kind of incredible genius in my
child but she's testing me and she's
forcing me
she's forcing me to give up on me yeah
that's right which is way more important
yeah i mean way bigger obviously way
more important but it also feels like
some kind of weird reset button for sure
like i know that i'm never gonna be the
dude i was in front of this this woman
you know and i know that i'm never gonna
treat my wife the way that i treated her
around this woman it's almost like
having the ultimate parole officer
it's like the ultimate probation officer
i've never looked down on having a
probation officer i need somebody to
keep me accountable because freedom
without guidelines and limitations is
[ __ ] madness you know if i strip you
naked and throw you in the ocean you'll
be free but you won't enjoy it you know
i need
i need like i need guidance and my kid
is serving as some kind of ultimate like
um
like horse star yeah and
for sure north star but even more than
that she's
first of all my kid is so [ __ ] joyful
like she's just always i've been around
doctors and maybe all doctors say this
but like
i've been around dr saying like this is
the most joyful kid i've ever been
around you know she's raised in complete
love and my wife is such a good mother
she's a part of a new purpose that i
that i didn't have you know i was living
for myself and when you're holding a
baby like you don't care about none of
your [ __ ] you know like what do you
think being a good dad is what what are
you going to bring to the table i'm
honest yup i'm loyal
uh
i'm willing
i'm uh open curious super curious and uh
i'm uh i'm learning how to
how to be
a man of principles give voice to what
you're scared of and what you're worried
about about being a dad and and and what
you think uh you know you need to focus
on and what you're worried about with
your relationship with her for the
future i'm not worried about much
anymore like i don't live in fear i
don't have a bunch of worry like that
what do you need to work on yeah there's
a lot i need to work on first off just
in terms of having a daughter and
knowing that your daughter is one day
gonna search your name in a search
engine and see that you know
you are a deplorable
disgusting
[Music]
uh
piece of [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] hits you know and so i i
have
i have from now until she's uh literate
to create a relationship with her where
she knows me more than this
this idea who i am in the public you
know
when that hits like you like you say
because it's funny man i i i just went
through something like that with my kids
because my kids can [ __ ] read now you
know what i mean and uh
what what what's there man do you see an
opportunity in that yeah what is it i'm
i i picture for myself for christmas
with a bunch of people i don't helped
there you go that's what i envisioned
for myself it's not you know i
i used to judge my worth by the films
and stuff and
like i think about my christmases
during that whole
path it was just so [ __ ] solitary and
lonely or to be like this new girl and
that i mean it was always like some
like very um in intangible
rapid vapid no intrinsic value nobody
that could like
i imagine that there's dudes i'm working
with now that i got 597 days of
this program i'm in and um i got monks
at my house you know i look around
sometimes in my house even now and i
think what
like how you know how did this happen
and um
i think it's the relationships i think
my daughter will be able to
when it does come time for her to be
able to assess who her father is she'll
see a man who
failed was a sinner was honest about it
that's it took accountability for it and
then made course corrections that's it
changed and then gave his life to
something bigger than himself and
found solace in
a program of principles service love
you know that's that's where i'm aiming
at so
i think it'll be a christmas one day
where she just wakes up and goes damn
dad's got a lot of friends who are these
people and my mommy will say like you
know dad had a hand to play in like
these people finding the same thing he
found
that's what i i'm hoping for you know
not if but when she falls because
everybody does man sure
you're going to be able to talk about it
with her and you're going to be able to
be there with her the reason i've always
connected to you is because you know you
have depth and weight because you done
fell on your [ __ ] face you know and
then got back up and kept it moving and
you know this is people who haven't gone
through that they don't have depth and
weight to the the message that they have
to share they can tell you all about
what to do and how you're supposed to do
it but very few people have the life
experience and this child is a big part
of that you know there's a lot of
miracles that have taken place in my
life
just in this short period of time that
that that takes me out of this belief
phase into like
oh i can touch it yeah this feels very
real so
and i i played with faith you know when
we did fury i was toiling with faith but
it was all like the purpose was
performative what was your it was it's
about intentionality right right to be
good in the movie right not to save
yourself or save somebody else and when
i [ __ ] up in the past it's like you
know you get a call from brad pitt what
[ __ ] up you know there wasn't no calls
this time yeah
my mother didn't talk to me this time
you know nobody all my all my friends
became acquaintances the antithesis of
being a friend is walking away i am not
going to walk away like i am always
going to love you i am always going to
support you
that being said the things that
you know this person said like i can't i
can't [ __ ] with that and like and like
what you said you were right man like i
i [ __ ] hurt people in my life you
know like i know what that is i know
what it's like to be in that valley i
know what it's like to be left behind um
i don't know what it's like
you know
to put my hands on a woman or for a
woman to say i put my hands on her and
and that's something i you know like
but no matter what the the case is
my job as your friend
is
to in whatever way you allow me to or
you allow me to be a pro part of that
process is to make sure one you never do
it again make sure to that that that
you're in a healthy process
and and number three that i'm a support
system for why you're going through that
um
so i guess my question with that is
man's like where am you answered it a
little bit but
where are you and what do you what four
four people who support you and love you
like what do you want to say to them
yeah i mean i got a men's to make i got
a long list of people that i need to
make amends to and so
um what i want to say to those people is
i i want to get it you know it doesn't
seem you know when it first hit it was
like
you know i wanted to air it out and talk
about specifics and like none of it
really matters you know i hurt that
woman you know and in the process of
doing that i hurt many other people and
many other people before that woman you
know i was living my life
i was a pleasure-seeking selfish
self-centered
dishonest
inconsiderate fearful human being and i
was operating on a
on a survival instinct i wasn't
operating as a friend i didn't actually
all my loves
and friendships were transactional you
know i [ __ ] with you because we worked
together and i experienced great
pleasure in that working situation
you know uh
when i look back at the friendships who
people who
who dipped or don't talk to me these
were also part of the same kind of
transactional relationships i didn't
actually understand what love was you
know i didn't know what friendship was
i'm not trying to do a pity party thing
i was raised very specifically in in in
my father would tell me stuff like
you know your life is your life son you
know if you want to have a good life you
got to work real hard you gotta get into
a good school you gotta get a good job
that'll lead to a good relationship you
have a kid and you put that kid in a
good school and you know it's all up to
you
and so that kind of
it forced me into a position in my life
where i was god
i was
the
person who was making [ __ ] happen
and
um
and i was using people like like like i
was um in a laboratory measuring [ __ ]
and like
um
quite controlling i mean you know how i
am on set too you know the way i was
operating on set was
the actor is the poet you know like
you're in a solitary you're on your own
like journey that's a bunch of nonsense
but this is what i was living in it's
the [ __ ] i came up with you know
the actors that i looked up to the the
art that i was inspired by
uh
they moved like the actor is the poet i
was moving like in my life like i was
that way right that does something to
the way you operate in the world some
people are attracted to it because that
confidence is attractive
and it feels comforting to be around
somebody who who you think knows
something
it's attractive it it calms my own
insecurity to be around a person who
who is fully acquainted and acclimated
to their craft or their mission in life
when somebody's really confident in
something it's nice to be around that
energy because it feels like
guidance it feels like you can lean on
it yeah they got to figure it out they
got it figured out right so i get why
why
i'm i empathize with why my way of doing
[ __ ] was attractive then
and i remember who you were on that set
i remember how
fearful how deeply insecure you know and
sure and the way that you were moving on
that show specifically
and then the yearnings for david to hit
you with certain compliments and [ __ ]
like you know you needed validation
from him for sure from us
from kevin
more so from kevin you know and like the
military dudes you constantly needed
them to co-sign all your [ __ ] all the
time and
i i empathize with that but that's not
who i was i was not
that way in life
uh
the way that i felt about craft and life
in general was
i don't give a [ __ ] what you think you
know i don't care what you think about
me i had come from
an environment with very little
um
cheerleading going on and so i created a
sort of um
survival instinct
where
i would cut people out you know and and
minimize opinions and the way that i
would do that is i had to
i had to
believe that my opinion was great
greater than everybody else's opinion
around me i remember i remember talking
[ __ ] to spielberg i mean there was no
director who ever directed me you know
and and i used to be proud of that
this is what i mean like my
the the things that i looked up to and
romanticized was i came up on a certain
kind of music a certain kind of culture
boss [ __ ] you know the guys i looked up
to were not
asking you what you thought i thought it
was something there was something sexy
and punk rock about like these islands
these men who were islands untouchable
yeah is that possible is it possible to
be there it's nonsense yeah it's just
not real this this the
it's um it's fiction it's not a real
it's a blanket right i mean it's armor i
listen to mickey rourke interviews and i
think damn bro it's a sad boy
you scared man you're so [ __ ] scared
you know
and there's a lot of this tough guy
armor [ __ ] and i get it you know and i
love mickey roar you know he gives me
hope
when you see a dude
go for 12 years no craft and then come
out and do the wrestling a guy like me
who's in my position looks up to [ __ ]
like that it gives me hope it makes me
feel inspired like all right if i'm
patient for 12 years maybe one day guys
like me in my position
need stories like that
and simultaneously i listen to his
interviews and i go there's no
evolution here
there's no you're still [ __ ] on tom
cruise bro like
why right
and it's insecurity right you know and i
was that way i was so competitive my
acting wasn't collaborative it was
competitive
it was a sport
and
my life was this way and this is what
created the insecurity and the jealousy
that put hands on this woman
the the man that was involved in that
relationship was
constantly comparing himself to other
people
and i was a dishonest person in that i
was wearing this mask you know i i've
gotten cold sores my whole life got them
from my mother i get two cold sores a
year when i'm stressed out or i'm sick i
never told any of my sexual partners
about getting cold sores never
and that's something when you talk about
like how do you
what you know
how do you how do you talk to these
people who you done [ __ ] over like
there's certain [ __ ] you can't clean up
yeah you know you can't
make amends for permanent damage like
that you know and so
my daughter now has become this
opportunity for me you know and every
woman in my purview has become an
opportunity for me to be like a stand-up
dude
i used to open doors for women yeah and
i used to you know i was a good dude
that way but it was almost performative
it was almost like i'll do this good
thing so you can think i'm a good dude
but like in my own private life when the
doors were closed
i never told any woman i had cold sores
you know and so um
that's that's
deplorable behavior you know when a
woman would like me it felt like so
[ __ ] foreign that i didn't want to
[ __ ] it up
and i always thought that a woman being
into me was tied to this business
so like i think about why the business
and the industry was so important for me
and it really
has almost little very little to do with
the craft itself and the spiritual
nature of what the craft can be for a
great swath of time it had to do with
this is how i
how i define myself this is where i
build my ego so that i can go in and
pursue these
the these
these things that will um
these feelings that will
absolve me from the very real feeling
that is continual
loneliness and
the feeling of being not enough
and the feeling of constantly comparing
yourself to other people
and
what that does in a relationship is it
makes you
it makes you controlling and fearful and
manipulative to not tell somebody you
get cold sores twice a year is the is a
heinous manipulation you know
um
but i never came up with a dude who was
like hey this is how you navigate that
situation nobody hit me to game like hey
bro you know if you're really in love
you can have open conversations about
uncomfortable [ __ ] and really get to
like another kind of connection you
don't even know about or if somebody was
trying to tell you you weren't in a
place to to receive it anyways i mean
maybe something that's right yeah yeah
it wasn't and and i get look you you
said
whether it was through you know drinking
or whatever the [ __ ] it was that you you
hurt people that are are close to you
yeah yeah that really that really
resonated with me man and and i'm just
wondering um i mean people who who put
their whole [ __ ] on the line to like
bring me back from the fire
you know alma harel is a great example
of a person who she took a gamble on me
you know i was in rehab when we started
having a conversation i got arrested in
georgia for fighting with a cop wound up
in rehab
and uh
didn't hear a damn thing about
god spirituality personal growth
accountability my whole as soon as i got
to rehab was let me get back to this
hustle
so i started writing a script in rehab
that's how [ __ ] mad i was i wasn't
listening to no therapy i had been
therapist my whole life that it felt
like you want me to focus on the problem
well how am i gonna like how am i gonna
hack this focusing on the problem thing
and how am i gonna find my way back to
this [ __ ] hustle so i can get back to
my ego because really all i cared about
was my ego i didn't give a [ __ ] about
getting well you know it was all about
get well for you get well for the camera
get well and so you know honeyboy was
born in this kind of toxic
milieu of
false
recovery
uh
false recovery masked as some kind of
like uplifting product uh
and she was in on it because she thought
that it was i mean i don't know what her
motivations were but it felt like she
was she was doing kind of what you're
doing here when the conversation first
started with alma it was like man we got
to get to the root of what the [ __ ] is
going on here you know something wrong
with you you know let's get well it's
out of love it was out like y'all [ __ ]
with each other you made stuff together
i love you what can we do it wasn't it
wasn't let's build a product it wasn't a
fetishizing product when we first it
wasn't like i was in an environmental
academy award yeah let me let me go hit
you up for a script idea it wasn't that
she hit me up like hey i'm in the same
i'm i'm living a principled life also
maybe you should get you know get get
involved in this thing
and immediately i was on a you know as a
matter of fact you know here's a [ __ ]
60-page monologue i wrote about my dad
while i was doing this fourth step you
know and right away it was almost like i
manipulated her into directing this
movie and then that put me in a
situation where i was even sicker
because then self-will is run riot in
full because now i'm at sundance we just
done one sundance and i'm like
thinking that i can like
that i'm the ultimate
um
manipulative master and i was and i was
telling other people who would come to
me after seeing that movie asking me
about how to help and i would tell them
well you just got to paint with your
pain
you know and all this [ __ ] nonsense
it just wasn't i had no spiritual life
none the fact that the fact that your
spiritual life at that point was
bankrupt and the fact that that came out
of a transactional uh less than weak
part of you if that's if that's what
you're saying yeah
is it still possible that through the
art that you made that that had inspired
people or helped people it's it still
could have oh i know it has
okay uh and i don't think
and i don't get too um
spiritual too uh too much god talking
here because i know that it landed like
on deaf ears when i wasn't ready but yep
god uses people in in many ways and i've
interacted with people and alma has
interacted with people who that movie
has has had a hand in
helping them find their way back to the
route you know and
and uh that's very fulfilling so i can't
deny that that that craft and art is a
huge
instigator and people you know when you
think about catholicism in full you know
beauty is a huge part of the religion
that's right art has a huge
uh hand in evangelizing people and
bringing them to god and so
but there's also been some real toxicity
and some morally bankrupt things that
use that art in order to draw people in
for own personal gain and for weak parts
of those people which is where i was
and i think man you know it's you know
when i think about you you have this
ability
um to inspire and to galvanize and
ignite people
you can make people feel um enormously
strong and powerful and and joyous
i've also seen you
completely humiliate people yeah i've
seen you um
completely
destroy the joy and
you know in an environment you know and
that's and and i think these things
they're cousins man like you cannot have
one without the other and it is a
constant i think it is a constant
work it is a constant mission if you're
going to try to if you're going to try
to walk the path where you're trying to
live for positivity you're trying to
bring people up because that doesn't go
away that [ __ ] will never ever go away
and it's constant work yeah and and
the thing that i was tripping out on is
you saying how you hurt people close to
you that that's also i i i you know
we've talked about it i definitely
understand what it's like to hurt people
i've hurt people i've heard people in
ways i have i i i'm disgusted with
myself for what i've done yeah um i
haven't heard people that that are close
to me i can't imagine what that's like
and i want to know
first i guess i i want to know how does
that feel do you know that you're doing
that
while you're doing it and what is the
realization like what is it what does
that feel like to know you've done that
or to know you're doing that yeah i mean
uh
so there's there's there's two uh
perspectives on it there's where i am
now and who i was then yeah and i've had
to do a lot of inventory on what was
motivating this perspective
i come from like and this isn't a boohoo
[ __ ] either but i know abandonment i
know like deuces
and
i uh would test relationships and as a
way of like finding
finding a barometer i'd also like i
would hurt people just out of straight
selfishness no like there's no
intellectual facet to it just the fact
that you know uh
the fact that i cheated on every woman
i'd ever been with you know uh
the fact that that
directors who put me on
who took me from nothing and put me on
i eviscerated in public life even on set
when i would sense weakness in another
person on the other side of a scene
i would lean in
i wouldn't try to uplift nobody i would
try to lean in
and it was this constant trying to
define myself in the world it has it has
to do with not feeling enough you know
all
all of this comes from fear just
when i have no
i didn't understand masculinity in full
you know um
what i know masculinity to be now is
stability you know you can't really have
stability if you're running [ __ ]
because if you're just a dude like
you're you know how infinitesimally
[ __ ] small we don't even know how
deep lake michigan is you know like what
are you really running you're running
nothing right and so this idea that
if you're if you're like uh
if your boss in your life
you're always going to be
in in in a tremendous amount of fear
and
denial right in denial it's just not
real yeah you have to you have to deny
anybody else's god you have to deny god
in full and you have to
you know you fall into this like sam
harris christopher hitchens hole where
you're trying to intel intellectualize
everything and rationalize it you're
fragile dude we're all fragile yeah but
then you then you get caught up with
like you know how you hung out with like
philosophers and [ __ ] you know i would
backstop all my [ __ ] with like these
philosophies and like [ __ ] words you
know
play these word spells on people
and uh was using like performance art to
like create this uh you know running
word spells you know just a bunch of
[ __ ] nonsense really at the end of
the day
uh
that all had to do with the very with
the same thing that hurt people it was
all about
i had my propulsion system was [ __ ] my
motivations behind the way i was living
my life was wrong you know
i had to get a new propulsion system i
wasn't looking at life like how can i be
useful to other people
i wasn't looking to be of service to
nobody even including a director i
listen to ethan hawk sometimes you know
uh
do interviews about how he looks at the
craft and he's always talking about like
my job is just to be in service of the
director and that's like foreign to me
yeah you know i remember being in
service to a director and getting [ __ ]
over i remember doing movies with
certain dudes who like led me down a
weird path and looking back at the
project thinking like nah man i was
right all along you were wrong and then
i just i stopped listening to any kind
of director you know and that innocent
dude who came into the industry with all
this wild wide-eyed wonderment that
disappeared pretty quick and then it
became
like uh
i got around some dudes who i saw work a
very specific way
and i thought the answer to this
is the answer to this um
having to rely on the infallible man
that is the director is you just don't
listen to the director and you just do
your own [ __ ] because trust your
instincts buddy cause you're god
i remember calling my manager and saying
like what do you mean i'm god
you know this is really where i was at
because i thought
my craft was was god i thought
love art and god all meant the same
thing to me and and to somebody who's
who's because i understand you're
looking at it from two different
perspectives it's where you're at now
and where you were where you were going
through it so for somebody who may be
going through that right now or for
somebody who
you know maybe is close to somebody who
is going through that were there ever
times of empathy were there ever times
of realization were there ever times a
shame when you're like [ __ ] i just hurt
that person what would you say to that
dude i'll tell you like this i remember
being in georgia when i was doing this
movie with this kid zach you were there
for part of it yeah and i remember
getting arrested yeah and i remember
getting out of jail
the next day and i remember sitting down
with zach
and there were moments of like like
lucid articulation from this man
and this happened to be one of them and
he said you know this is my one shot
you make movies all the time but this is
my one shot
and you're ruining it for me
and
to say that you don't feel that when it
lands is not true i felt it deeply but
it's what you do with that feeling you
know do you change
and i didn't you know i would always
like i always had an inch left
i always had some [ __ ] wiggle room
every time i would [ __ ] up there was
always some wiggle there was always a
brad pitt on the phone there was always
some like you know sundance some next
project there was always alma there was
always another there was always wiggle
room to get back into ego and this time
there wasn't no wiggle room that's why i
attribute this woman with save on my
life because she she she destroyed any
route towards that wiggle that's real it
is real rock [ __ ] bottom rock bottom
bottom isn't when you experience the
worst moment of your life bottom is when
you change right it's when you actually
it's when you touch it when you smell it
when it's right on your face yeah you
feel it and then it's not about severity
of what the thing is it's not it's about
what you do with it once it happens so
like
once once once it happened i mean when
it landed i forgot how to breathe you
know because the email the subtext of
the email was
your hustle's over
you know uh and i forgot how to breathe
and i the next thing i did after two
minutes of sitting there
looking at staring at a computer screen
was i went and loaded up a gun and sat
at my table and was gonna kill myself i
was out of here i didn't know what to do
anymore like all my ideas had failed and
i sat there for two minutes thinking
where is the wiggle room
i'd already used my play yeah what's the
play
uh
and there were no options it was like
there was nowhere to go it's not like i
could go outside and get a choco taco
and chill on the you know
people driving down the street rolling
down the window like [ __ ] off and die
you know this is where i was in the
early days of this [ __ ] so i didn't even
want to leave my house
and i had a woman living in my house who
wasn't my wife
and i was on my way to go do some movie
i didn't give a [ __ ] about you know just
like momentum building kind of [ __ ] you
know movies no intrinsic value just like
i need something on the cards you know
for this year i need my two or three
products one of these things
and
um
and i felt disconnected from all of it
and
i wound up getting emails from certain
dudes who
who like you were still involved in my
life even when it got ugly you know when
it got chunky one of those dudes was
sean penn and sean's like you need to
call brolin
and i called brolin and he told me he
was going to this meeting online now the
gun is loaded like i haven't left my
sitting position you know and i wound up
signing on to this meeting and i heard
one of the dudes who was speaking that
night say
uh
if you're new and you just entered you
know you don't have everything you want
right now but you got everything you
need right now
now
now
now
now and he did that for like two minutes
and
the first minute i'm thinking you can't
spend the whole rest of your share just
snapping your fingers and saying now
like this [ __ ] is ludicrous and i went
into this judgment which is what my
alcoholism sounds like sounds like
criticality it sounds like judgment
so i'm in my judgment like you better
say and a gun is right here i'm like you
better say something that's really going
to get me the [ __ ] out of where i'm at
and after two minutes like i i felt like
a giggle start to rise inside of me and
i felt something like presence i stopped
thinking about the email stopped
thinking about my hustle the gun almost
disappeared and it was like i'm sitting
here on this this this skype call and
i'm present for the first time in my
life and i want to write in the dude in
the chat box like hey bro you know i'm
on the verge you know i'm about to kill
myself he's like okay cool call me
tomorrow
just like throw away you know and i
needed that i had been enabled for so
long in my life that if it was going to
be me walking into this program and
having a bunch of dudes pat me on the
back like hey man welcome home
we're glad you're here i'd have been out
again because then it would have been
more wiggle room
but the guy that i wound up running into
was not having it and
he said hey man uh meet me on the beach
tomorrow and i wound up
up here at tower 10 and he he said uh i
need you to get on your knees and i'm
like i'm not getting on my knees he's
like cool deuces he started walking away
i'm thinking oh [ __ ] but it also reified
this like you don't care
like you care but not in that way you
know you're not gonna pat me on my back
and i said okay okay i was i was so
willing at this point because i was in
so much [ __ ] pain
and he said get on your knees and i get
on my knees he gets on his knees with me
so right away it's no longer like this
power play we're like like collaborating
in this and he says i need you to stop
the waves
and i'm like ah man listen this dr quinn
medicine woman version of this [ __ ]
ain't gonna work with me you know like i
get how this goes he's like are you
either gonna write what happens or
you're gonna do a bunch of [ __ ] that you
don't believe in so that your life
changes because your issue is that you
you need to rationalize everything and
you're out of options son
like what
if not this what
and he was right and so i started saying
you know stop waves and he's like louder
man stop waves and he got up off of his
knees and he started walking away and i
look back and he's like nah keep going
and he's like keep saying it again i say
stop waves he's like louder brother all
the way over there you're all the way
over here stop them waves man and now
i'm yelling and i'm having like an
emotional it almost feels performative
now now i'm like back in my bag back to
like the manipulating hustling like
wiggle room
yeah watch this boom let me let me and
then i'm crying and i'm stop waves you
know like i'm in the middle of like the
the greatest monologue of my life on
this beach
yeah
exactly
and uh
and uh he puts his hand on my shoulder
and he goes you can stop all that
which made me like giggle you know i
started giggling and then he stood up
and he put his hand on my left shoulder
and put his hand on my right shoulder
and he said
welcome to aaa
and uh
it did something to me that felt like
like
it felt like warrior [ __ ] yeah i didn't
it felt like like like man code like g
[ __ ] it didn't feel like fluffy cute
[ __ ] book reading sitting in a it felt
like you're on a mission yeah it felt it
felt purposeful and it felt sexy to be
honest with you sexy in the way that
listening to kevin vance feels sexy to a
young man who feels like a boy it felt
so rooted
and it wasn't emotional it wasn't
performative he wasn't trying to
manipulate me but it was kind of hokey
and like the nights which knights in
shining armor kind of hokiness that like
made me feel like a little kid again and
he said i need you to go home and clear
out like clear the decks and i'm like
nah man like
for me and i don't know if you felt this
way but every woman was the one for me
there was never a two if you liked me
you were the one
and
that had to do with my insecurity and my
fear like i didn't have no there was no
two or three or i was just dating like
like frivolously it was always like this
grand hair climbing up the
super emotional super uh romantic super
uh this fierce romance you know that i
was searching for desperate little boy
[ __ ] and he said you gotta clear the
decks and i'm like i don't know if i can
do that man you know i i feel like she's
the one and he's like giggling to
himself you know this isn't my wife my
wife is not involved in my life at this
point
and i got this one who's not the one who
accused me of this [ __ ] and she's just
another person who's who's been uh
trapped in my sphere of uh of influence
and she's living in my house and he's
like uh well look man i tell you what
you know you can keep doing it your way
or you can try some new [ __ ] because the
way that you're living it's [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] you're fully [ __ ] you're doomed
is what he said you're doomed that was
the word
and um
i flipped to this page he made me flip
to this doctor's opinion we got in our
book and in the doctor's opinion or how
our book starts it it mentions the word
doomed and he's like this isn't like
another a.a guy this is a doctor telling
you you're doomed if you don't figure
this [ __ ] out and uh he goes to put it
in perspective if you went to kaiser
permanente right now
and they sat you down and put your you
know x-rayed you and put your your x-ray
up on a light board and you're looking
at a picture of your clavicle and the
doctor said hey man you said that gray
spot just above your chest cavity you're
doomed
what would happen to you was your
[ __ ] would suck you would [ __ ]
start sweating bullets and you wouldn't
be thinking about the job that you got
to get to or the girl you got to hold on
to or where you're going to go on the
for father's day or what that you
immediately your whole life would get
very small and the only rational
response to that kind of information is
well what do i do
and if i told you to staple a dog's dick
to your [ __ ] chin and walk up and
down the street picking a cigarette
butts you would do it you wouldn't ask
me why or whether you believe in it or
nothing you go look for a dog you know
and so uh
that made sense to me he puts me in a
car he says i need you to listen to
sandy beach tape now at this point in my
life like i'm
i'm i'm like barely hanging on and i'm
i'm using this woman like drugs you know
every time i need validation i'm having
like i'm with this woman and and she
becomes what the job the mask of success
that the job created for me which kept
me from like really looking at myself
she became that for me in the interim
and he's like you got to get rid of all
of it you know
there is no more work and no more
romance for for a year you're going to
have to give me a year and i'm thinking
like i'm not gonna be able to pull that
off you know
and right away i'm half measuring and
this is my wiggle room i i can't and uh
he says
i need you to download this tape this
sandy beach tape sandy beach is a big
speaker
uh
and in this in this what was the speech
yeah the speech was he's talking about
this this chinese farmer
and uh
chinese farmer in the sun they're
picking radishes about the ground and
they don't own the land that they're
farming off of
and uh they're barely subsisting they're
giving 70 to the land owner they're
living off of 30 of these radishes their
whole financial legacy is tied up into
this workhorse and one day and the sun
is really working the land because the
man is too old and one day the workhorse
runs up off the hill he just [ __ ] off
he's up the hill and the son runs into
the house and he shakes his dad up and
he says dad you're not gonna believe
this is a this is a travesty we're gonna
die out here uh i can't get these
radishes to grow unless i turn this land
over and i can't move that hoe without
the horse and the horse is gone this is
a nightmare and the old man non plus
looks at his son he goes i don't know
what this is son i don't know if it is a
nightmare i can't call it
and the son thinks his dad's out to
lunch or like ambivalent or something's
wrong or he's too old and a couple days
later the kid is chilling on the porch
and he sees the horse running down the
hill with 50 wild stallions behind it
and they run into the paddock and he
locks the paddock and he runs inside and
he hits the daddy he's like man this is
[ __ ] radishes like we're rich you know
we're we're in the horse business we're
in the horse trading business now this
is a miracle dad i'm gonna go tell
everybody we're trading horses now and
the father looks at his son nonplussed
again and says i don't know what this is
i don't know if it's a miracle i can't
call it
and a couple more days pass and
the sun's trying to break these horses
down domesticate these horses he doesn't
know anything about horse he's a radish
farmer so
one of the horses ain't having it he
rears up kicks him in his leg it's like
1400's china there's no kaiser
permanente his [ __ ] is shattered they
wrap them in some like tobacco leaves or
some sprinkle cement on it go sit in a
chair for a while and uh and he's
wailing and the townspeople hear about
it and towns people run up on the little
shack and oh man what are you gonna do
you know you can't domesticate these
horses you can't move this hoe you guys
are fully [ __ ] i don't know what
you're gonna do but this is this is
pretty much the end right like this is a
nightmare and the old man says i don't
know what this is he looks at his son's
leg he goes i don't know what this is i
can't really call it
a couple more days pass he's sitting
with his son he's trying to calm down
he's in the middle of pain and they hear
this thunderous noise and they look up
on the ridgeline and they see
5000 samurai on horseback running
towards their little hut and the
commanding officer gets off his horse
and says give us your son we're going to
fight the maoist army
and he looks at his son's leg and he
looks back at the samurai army and he
goes
i would but he can't get out the chair
you know he
he can't get on his he can't no i can't
i would but i can he's crippled and
the man gets back on his horse and 8 000
men right off to their death
and i listen to this tape
and
and i i i'm driving back from the beach
back to where i'm living and i get out
of my car and her bags are packed
she's on her way out
and old me
would have written a haiku poem in blood
and ripped my shirt off hulk hogan style
ran down the street and jumped over the
fence and
that guy the climb the hair up the thing
yeah yeah boombox in the air guys what i
came up on and something in me from
having heard what i just heard
what feels like this is this is now i
can't get no lower i hear this like i
can't call it and this it becomes like
this the most diplomatic breakup i ever
had in my life and i say what can i do
and sh and uh can i get you a car and
she goes no don't worry about it go get
well
and i go walk into my house and i call
my dude up and i'm like man i think this
[ __ ] is working like man this is a
miracle like this is the most diplomatic
thing i ever and i'm in my meeting i'm
telling all the dudes like i think this
program is really working in my life man
and then i got five days sober and
they're like bro i think you're pink
cloud why don't you go to another
[ __ ] meeting jack
and uh and i go on to this other meeting
now the whole time i've been doing this
for the first five days i'm on the phone
with a lawyer like look this is true but
this isn't true and i got receipts for
this and i'm not going to do this and
pop up and i'm fighting fighting
fighting tooth and nail i'm on the phone
with the agents and the manager's like
listen you gotta believe me and blah
blah blah doing that [ __ ] right
and uh my sponsor's telling me the whole
time he's like
look you're gonna have to let go dog
like the wind's at your back just let go
you know all this like fighting [ __ ]
around like let go man that's childish
and and i'm hearing him but i'm not
doing it you know i'm on the phone i'm
on the phone with him and i'm hanging up
the phone i'm fighting this thing and i
got a lawyer who's like you need to go
to rehab for anger management because
when you go to court no spot no aa is
going to mean [ __ ] you know
addicts that already juiced that route
for so long that don't mean nothing we
need clinical receipts that you're doing
something right
and i'm like i'm not going to rehab
that's like that's
i've always really like cultivated my
brown bagger right like i don't like
wearing new shoes so this idea that i
was gonna pay all this money to go pet a
horse and make a friendship bracelet it
felt like man this shit's like that's
not sexy you know i found aa for real
i'm really in my [ __ ] now i don't want
to
uh i don't want to go to this rehab
i don't want to go to it because
somebody's saying that's going to get
you off
it's all about the intentionality you
got to not stop it's not about not
saying the right thing because you're
worried about getting in trouble you say
the right thing because you believe the
[ __ ] right thing it's that and it's
also i'd already done this right i'd
already gone to rehab wrote a script and
played that game you know and uh right
and to focus
and it didn't work it didn't work it
didn't work to focus on like my
childhood trauma isn't where my problem
lies my problem doesn't lie in what
people did to me what led you to a place
with more wiggle room and now you don't
have it and so and so and i'm telling
them no i don't want to do this you know
and i'm telling the lawyer like i don't
want to do this and look yeah this and
this and i'm fighting all this [ __ ] and
i signed on to this a.a meeting
this is where i'm talking about like
miraculous [ __ ] started to pop off in my
life and my sp my dude sent me there
because his mom was taking a chip for
like 37 years and the woman who took a
chip right after his mother was the
woman i lost my virginity to
who when i was 19 years old i held a
knife to her neck
and everything in that moment it felt
like i heard god's voice say i'm
everywhere
you can't run no more
and like my whole [ __ ] all my
planning and like all this like
just went gone
and um
that really happened you know and i
remember it vividly
and i wrote her in the chat box like did
my dude tell you to come like do you
know this guy and this guy she's like
nah i'm in here because my people are
getting chips you know but it's good to
see you i knew you were on your way here
you know i hope you get it this time
and um
so
i called my dude up and he's like bro
you got to let go you got to let go in
full and i want to get in my car and i
drive up to utah and i'm in utah for
three months and while i'm in utah it
allows me it gives me they take my cell
phone from me
and if they didn't take my cell phone
from me i was never going to be able to
deal with what i needed to deal with i
had never known how to pray because i
could never cultivate silence
i had no absence in my life every
unforgiving minute was full of some
[ __ ] scroll or some more like ego
feed constant non-stop rotation of this
this ego thing and that ego thing and
just constant fulfillment of like my own
personal desires and they took my phone
from me and just for that reason alone i
would i would
urge anybody
to go this route if you're in a
situation like mine just to get the
[ __ ] phone out of your pocket
and what that gave me was time to like
really assess what had been my operating
systems
what had been like the motivational
force in my life which was always me it
was always ego it was always the
smallest decision the smallest decision
to even go into everything to everything
everything was ego everything was ego i
would eat that not because it tasted
good but because it would do this or do
that you know and um
so i was there for for 90 days and in
that 90 days i i uh
i made a list of all these people that i
hurt
and and um i mean a bunch of [ __ ]
happened but
uh i came out and um
just hit the ground running trying to
make amends trying to right these wrongs
this is also still a part of that
there's some people who don't want to
talk to me you know
and uh and i understand that and so my
purpose now is to be patient
is there an example that you can think
of that you're i don't know if the right
word is proud but if you feel good about
sort of where you guys got to or you
feel good about the process in terms of
making amends or and there's growth yeah
can you give me an example of that yeah
see i didn't even know what a men's
meant just like i didn't know what
prayer was but um
and let me let me let me find my way to
what you just said but like um
part of what happened to me up there was
uh
i would get quiet and i started hearing
like like loving thoughts
for people that on paper were like
villainous characters in my life
so i would get quiet and i was you know
the first 20 thoughts is like you got to
do this you got to do that go here go
there go get this
and then there'd be like the 30th
thought that's like
hit your dad up tell him you love him
now me and my dad weren't talking you
know and um
and this is how my prayer life works now
it's like i get quiet i hear loving
thoughts and then when i act on these
loving thoughts miraculous [ __ ] happens
in my life you know i wind up in service
or uh and then i feel peace but also
like i get all these like incredible
like with my dad i want to hit my dad up
now here's a man who i don't vilified on
a grand scale i put all this [ __ ] in the
street
you know uh and used him juiced my dad
is like this is the reason i'm [ __ ]
foul out here you know i'm come from
this wayward upbringing and you know my
dad is the reason i'm such a [ __ ] up you
know he's a a biker and a wild man and a
criminal and a duda and abusive about
and i and i wrote this narrative which
was just [ __ ] nonsense
my dad was so loving to me my whole life
fracture sure crooked sure like
wonky for sure but never was not loving
once never was not there he was always
there he was always there
and i done a world press tour about how
[ __ ] he was as a man
honey boy is basically like
a big woe is me story about how [ __ ] my
father is
and i i wronged him
and
i remember getting on the phone with him
and him and being like you know i never
read this stuff in the scripture sin you
know because i because i didn't put that
[ __ ] in there you know and i was i was
bullshitting him i was you know just
trying to get him to sign his [ __ ]
piece of paper
he thought i was gonna tell the story of
like braveheart you know i was gonna and
i didn't i didn't you know i told the
story like this this uh
this dude who and i and i turned the
knob up on certain [ __ ] that wasn't real
my dad never hit me
never
he spanked me once
one time
and the story that gets painted in
honeyboy is like this dude was like
abusing this kid all the time you know
my dad tried to keep me from smoking
cigarettes that's when he spanked me he
found me smoking cigarettes in the
shower he pulled me out he spanked me
that's when he spanked me but that
wasn't my narrative because it didn't
position me as like this wounded
fractured child that you could root for
which is what i was using him for so
when i got on the phone with him i you
know i uh
i took accountability for all that and
knew very clearly that i couldn't take
it back
you know my dad was going to live with
this certain narrative about him on a
public scale for a very long time you
know probably the rest of his life and i
didn't put all the [ __ ] in the street
you know uh the [ __ ] that my dad got
arrested for happened like 30 years ago
and i didn't brought it all back to the
surface you know
and um
and i and i i i told them you know what
i was doing and
it went just like you know hey man i'm
i'm in this program i'm learning to be a
decent man one day at a time
uh i know i didn't [ __ ] you over over
here you know i don't put your [ __ ] in
the street and i know i made it harder
for you to move around in the world and
and uh i defined you as like this
villainous character when really you
were like a an amazing dude for me in my
life and like you know i really look up
to you and and the way that you've moved
through your failings and the father
that you've been to me you've been a
great man to me and uh
um
if there's ever anything i can do be it
blood counsel money whatever if there's
ever anything i can do to make your life
better in any way please don't hesitate
to let me know
and um
my dad was living in costa rica on his
[ __ ] cocaine farm at the time you
know
and uh
living with a bunch of nicaraguans and
like
he said i want to come home
and um
so i i got him back and uh when i
my dad was like me i was a big pothead
and so here i am with like i got like 10
months of sobriety i'm about to go pick
my dad up i'm in a weed shop
buying like 500 bucks worth the weed for
my dad
and uh sober
and i get in the bag and uh and i show
up at the the airport and my dad gets
out and i see my dad in a wheelchair
he's got copd dude could barely breathe
and i wheel his ass over the truck and i
put him in the truck and i give him a
joint he sparks up and he's coughing
like he's got blood and mucus coming out
he looks like
he looks like totally broken you know
and um
[Music]
little by little i start bringing him
back to health you know he's got eye
problems he fixed the eye problems he
found out he's pre-diabetic we go he
hadn't been to a doctor in like 10 years
you know when we get to the doctor
doctor's like if you smoke anything
you're going to die you got like 10 lung
capacity if you smoke anything or even
around incense you might die
and
my dad in the doctor's office looks at
me and goes i think i want to get sober
in the doctor's office he looks at me
goes i think i got i think i want to get
sober
so i bring him into my fold i bring him
into the group he starts going all this
[ __ ] with me we just we get get on it
together
that's probably like the crowning
achievement any amends that i made my
dad's got
he's got five and a half months now you
know and he's working with other dudes
and like you carried the message that
way
uh
you know for my wife i'll be making
amends for the rest of my life you know
it's every day you know doing dishes
it's part of that amendment i got to
make you know
that's going to be a lifelong journey a
lot of these amends are going to be
lifelong journeys there's amends that
people don't want to talk to me you know
i gotta make a living amends i gotta i
gotta find another way to be a service
to the world in a way that
takes all that energy and creates
something uh valuable uh something
valuable for another person um i mean i
got a men's you know that that girl who
was on that meeting you know i reached
out to her she was in the in the program
so she she kind of knew what i was what
was going on and that that amends was
made me and alma had sort of made some
we bridge the gap there we're not like
talking every day but there's there's
been a we've i'm making contact
communication little by little you know
it's only been 597 days i'm still the
beginning of this whole journey in my
life which is gonna be for the rest of
my life
and um
and yeah i go to every single person out
unharmed and i try to figure out where i
can be of service to their life in any
way that's that's possible
and um
yeah sometimes it'll be like these these
these really
neon versions of it like with my dad and
then sometimes it'll be you know uh
vanessa kirby right like vanessa kirby
was on her way to go get an oscar when
all this [ __ ] landed you know
and um she's been supportive to me this
whole time but i remember she had to
answer for me out there because i wasn't
communicating i wasn't like
uh because i didn't have nothing to
communicate i was still like
you know like this little uh myopic
litigator my dude kept saying don't say
nothing just shut the [ __ ] up and start
working you know and so i wasn't out
there talking but she was in the middle
of promoting a movie and she had this
whole oscar campaign that was set up for
you know
and for the movie and the cast and hole
and my damage [ __ ] those chances up
because as you know this is a very
political thing it's not about the
quality of the material becomes like
this positioning political and like to
be attached to this heretic
wasn't sexy and so it [ __ ] up her
opportunities and so like making amends
there was you know how do you rewind
that you don't you know uh
and though she never asked me to like
to do anything you know i reached out
and she and we and we put it to bed as
best as we could you know um but that's
another person who was always she always
showed up she was always in my corner
even when it wasn't sexy
just like my wife it's like it's not
sexy to be married and have a kid with a
dude who's like this public
uh abuser of women you know
sometimes i i you know i'll go look up
uh
i'll go look up like the
the response to my woman's film you know
she had a movie came out not recently
and like there'll be comments like
you know i don't [ __ ] with this woman
because she [ __ ] with him
you know that that's heavy you know that
my wife is like how does that make you
feel terrible dog
explain terrible like terrible like like
you converge into the kind of shame that
makes you unproductive like you can make
yourself is that unfair
uh no it's not unfair you don't think no
it's not unfair but uh it's not even
about fair fairness i mean it's not even
about fair like fair don't really exist
you want fair go to pomona but there's
no fair in this life so we're not
thinking about like
the emotions are real yeah my
accountability doesn't take away the
very real
that comment that somebody feels that
way towards my wife and that uh looks at
her like she's somehow less than because
she's still in my corner and that we
share this bond you know that doesn't
feel good to be that that kind of
influence on somebody's life uh but
equally for me to put too much value
into another person's opinion is to
[ __ ] myself it's to [ __ ] my marriage
it's to put me in the shame spiral that
doesn't do the dishes no more now i'm
just in like my own little haiku room
you know just like spiraling into my
little woe is me [ __ ] again and and i've
been there and i've done done that you
know and so
my job isn't to feel right
my my purpose in life isn't to be happy
no more that's what my purpose used to
be which is such a shitty aim in life
my aim in life in totality my whole
purpose for existing in life was to be
happy
and
that's not that's not my purpose anymore
now yeah my purpose now is to be useful
and so it doesn't make me useful to my
wife to shame spiral on some [ __ ] like
that it makes me useful to my wife to
show up for my wife and be stable for my
wife when we take our kid to the
children's hospital and she's tripping
and i happen to have a relationship with
god that centers me at this point where
i can be in a city environment like that
and be able to hold it down in that
environment so that's what my amends
looks like today when my wife is
tripping and she looks at me like what's
going to happen because my my
my three-month-old baby has a uh
has a has a bump on her head that feels
like something scary you know and and we
know now it wasn't it was called a
hemogenoma
which is really scary when you first
catch that you know you feel like oh man
this is and my wife was
tripping and had this not all happened i
wouldn't have been able to show up from
my wife and be stable in that
environment and be able to look at her
and really know what i was saying when i
said god loves us you know we're he's
cheating in our favor be that radish
farmer's dad exactly exactly you know
man i i found you know there's been so
much resistance in my life just like
that i've touched personally people know
about my connection to you having you
come on and do this yeah [ __ ]
being like are you out of your mind you
need to run from that dude and it's like
it's just something that i've never
really be able to shoot but but a funny
little anecdote uh you know the last
time you came up
you know we had such a wonderful time we
we kicked it we kicked it like the kids
still
you know
they still do you know the the 5150 test
that you taught them yeah about the
about the picture and the box
they do it to everybody who walks in the
house like the little tricks the little
[ __ ] side clown tricks you taught my
kids they do it to everyone like my
little man like they still you you're
like a pie pie like
this huge presence in my kids lives and
that's your ability to touch you know
what i'm saying uh and when we spent
that day in ohio
you know my agents
all called me uh i think either right
before that right after that
and and were just like you know couldn't
we just have shya's number you know we
just feel like we could represent him
you know like this third like they would
have literally sucked the [ __ ] out of
your ass you know what i'm saying and uh
please you know we just want to write
you know they was just so thirsty you
know what i mean you know then this
stuff went down and some months later
you know i got to know beau and i got to
connect with bo and we decided to put
this thing on
you know at slauson and and it was this
beautiful event and these same very guys
were like you know if shia comes we
can't be there and the casting directors
that you're bringing to come see and
this is uh i mean for whatever it's
worth there's there's known inactive
members of a of a criminal gang in the
in the piece
but you've been accused of something and
and they they're no longer those people
that were the and and to me the
hypocrisy of of of where we're at in
discourse in this country period but
especially in this industry it just was
mind blowing to me and then and and on
one side when we can have convicted
murderers on this show who by by the way
i mean they've they've done the crime
and they've done the time and that work
has been done
but that's something that's celebrated
but then when i want to have you on the
same industry that you've given so much
to in the same industry
you know they they can't touch you and
does that hurt are you can you divorce
yourself because because that's not i i
don't imagine you're you're you care
about what those people think right
right now so how do you how do you
decipher the not because i'm sure what
you were saying it really hit me man
that you're driving down the street
people rolling down their window yeah
i mean you've been public for so long
man yeah and i think you've been dealing
with whatever [ __ ] scared like you know
like look i know what it's like to walk
in a room and everybody knows like i i
understand that now that everybody knows
who the [ __ ] you are you walk into a
room and it's like do they know you for
your art do they know you for your
scandal does it matter like like how do
you because that [ __ ] doesn't matter but
it does affect us it is like you're a
human being like can you divorce
yourself from the nonsense easily
it makes me useful
tell me
people don't question whether i was a
fuck-up my [ __ ] was neon so like my
message when i'm talking to a dude who's
in a similar situation i don't have to
do all this qualifying right right right
i don't gotta like walk you through all
the the bang bang right you know what i
mean like you know what it was right it
creates an avenue to be effective in
somebody's life
you know the reason beau is effective
down there is because nobody questions
him right it's like is his [ __ ] was neon
dew was the key holder of the pueblos
for a long period of time so when he's
moving around youngsters don't like
question need him to like i mean i i
remember being in like i was getting
ready to get and i had no business in
the middle of it but it was quite a
contentious thing running that theater
program down there there's a whole lot
of like race relations you had to deal
with down there you know and a whole lot
of like art kids from like
studio city would drive down to the hood
and like
after a while like the neighborhood was
like man [ __ ] all this [ __ ] like i don't
want you down here you know unless these
opportunities for people from this zip
code then get out of here
and and that became quite contentious
and i remember like
watching bo
go and talk down
every single one of these neighbors and
it was short conversations and it wasn't
rah-rah it was like
they knew right away they were talking
to
tribe
this is what i mean by like i'm in the
tribe of the fuck-ups and i'm like a um
a very public
um
a very public
sinner
very fallible person in the public
sphere and so what i think now my
purpose is is to not do this like
the other examples that we've had of how
to navigate something like this
which is to go after the woman or try to
like win a court case or like get back
into a [ __ ] movie or like get back on
it all you know my purpose and i mean
this with every fiber of my being is to
be instructive with my life so that i
can be a
an advertisement like a billboard for a
principled way of living and that this
[ __ ] on the other side of being being
where i was is still [ __ ] sexy it's
still glittery it's still fun i found my
smile on the other side of this [ __ ] i
learned how to laugh on the other side
of the [ __ ] like genuinely i found a
group of friends around me you know i
found purpose in my life this little
girl man i mean that's like that's
that's
even that as big as that is that's
almost an infinitesimal part of how
and feels almost like some cheesy
pre-written version of what's available
to a person when they start living
towards this purpose
uh
it's
[Music]
um complete alignment you know like when
your head heart and your spirit in the
universe are in alignment like
what this agent is saying you know it's
like uh you know bro i pray for dudes
like that every night before i go to
sleep i pray for all my cheerleaders and
all the naysayers
and then i ask god to give these people
everything he would give me like my life
is now
i have experienced ego death and what
that's allowed me to do is like open
myself up to being what dudes like
like brolin and and not to lump them all
to the same category and i probably
shouldn't even do that but other dudes
that you know mel i remember seeing mel
at the oscars with his head held high
and i thought you know i was sitting in
rehab this is the [ __ ] rehab but i
remember seeing that and thinking like
oh man i could do it you know
and this is i'm trying to present a
different version of that to the world
where it's like all right you know
the business aside and like all the ego
[ __ ] aside which really isn't my aim
anymore
like my life is incredible i'm so
[ __ ] blessed that's not
there's no cap in anything i just said
to you i got so much love in my life so
much joy in my life
fearlessness
that i didn't have before you know
a calm a serenity
my life is full and it's not full of
like the stuff that i was chasing before
not here to like find my way back into
nothing
those people who don't get down with me
they probably never will you know
uh
to say that i don't love the craft is
not true but it's secondary to this
other thing i got going on because this
is all temporary
and i don't want to get too far into
this route but like people may not
forgive me but i know that i have been
forgiven
you know
and i know that i am loved
and when you really know that in your
fiber and on a cellular level then what
people think about you is
you know like god bless them it's not
that it don't matter because to say that
like
i'm blessed in that i am in the public
sphere and that
people do have judgments about me i i'm
blessed for the judgments they keep me
in line you know uh
it's it's about perspective on it you
know like it's that it's that can't call
it [ __ ] you know uh
i wasn't supposed to be there
for whatever reason now he's got his
reasons but he's got you know there's a
bunch of other reasons that i wasn't
supposed to be there for that i think
about the jobs that i that i had that i
got fired from when this [ __ ] just
popped off and i think yeah i wasn't
supposed to be there you know
and there's a strange kind of weird
validation on the other side when when
like uh when you feel like you've been
saved from certain situations and like
if i sit for 12 years it's because i'm
supposed to be sitting for 12 years you
know if if i never work again that's
exactly what's supposed to be happening
like my purpose isn't tied up in my
craft like that anymore and the other
thing that's happened to me because i've
been
blessed with opportunity since this
should happen is
when i do show up my way of working is
totally different how so
it's free
it's free it's like
i mean i heard people talk about this
but it's not so like
controlling and nitpicking and trying to
figure out what i got in my pockets and
how i'm going to sit and let me do it
this way and like there's a perfect take
and a [ __ ] take and and like you know
it's not that anymore it really becomes
like this like a jazz routine with me in
the universe you know i pray before i do
[ __ ] i'll be looking at my co-workers
like bro i love you
you know i mean i guess like the
motivator isn't
it's a different propulsion system
and so yeah so even that has changed in
my life
and i never thought i was going to work
again and the fact that the job that i
got
to come back put me into the church
in a real way not in a way that i had
done it previously in a very real way
felt almost bigger than the job it still
feels bigger than the job yeah and so
um
i have a very defined version of god in
my life it's very defined and i needed
it to find now that may not be for
everybody and that's cool you know you
call it what you want at the end of the
day what it really is is it's just love
you know every great abrahamic text
talks about the same [ __ ] like god is
love and so i didn't know how i didn't
know what love was i didn't know what
that actually meant and what it is is
it's it's
selfless service for your fellows
that's what love is and so
i never had really done any of that i
had never been a part of any of that so
even slauson
even the theater school
was ego
it was straight up ego watch me
bring art to the hood
and and
you know looking back on it i could
navigate a little bit better because of
my upbringing and i didn't look like
such a [ __ ] square walking in because
i knew who to go to and how to move and
da da but at the end of the day it's the
same [ __ ] it's like virtue signaling you
know watch me go be of service
and then i advertised it on in on mass
you know watch me go do this thing it's
the [ __ ] that nobody sees it's the quiet
service it's the quiet small work that's
the stuff that actually is much more
fulfilling and really the the
that's really what's been motivating my
life it's the only reason i can like
wake up and have any respite in my life
some reason i can have any kind of
um
reprieve
from this non-stop monologuing that
happens in my head that will put me in a
shame spiral
you know i i could very easily walk into
a coffee shop in the middle of venice
and look around and watch people look at
me and write a whole monologue about how
you think i'm the elephant man and if i
really want to i could just go on
twitter and just scroll my name and just
fall into some kind of k-hole of
self-deprecating shame and darkness do
you ever do that anymore of course of
course that's why this is a daily thing
you know my ego doesn't just disappear
like ego death but that [ __ ]
will pop back up at a moment's notice
the minute i do anything good so prayer
what else like how do you keep it at bay
how do you keep it dead like how do you
extinguish it when it pops up on a daily
basis
having a kid is really helpful for
humility definitely because kid don't
care no no
that's really helpful she's very helpful
uh in keeping me humble um having a
squad being a part of a group
that
gives you
feedback in real time can you walk me
through the squats is that how often is
that it's a meeting it's every day 60
dudes
and yeah we meet every single day
6 p.m on zoom
we have bike rides on thursday we meet
up at the beach on sunday
you know we go to other groups and stuff
like that but it's like a squad it's
full-on it's like it's like a gang
and um
i get out of it with bogot gets out of
being in the pueblos
bo's not going to tell you about all the
bang bang [ __ ] he gets out he's going to
talk about the love that he gets in it
and the the
you know i remember bo telling me one
time i remember asking him questions
like you did like why did you join this
and he remember i remember telling me a
story about how like
he was in the middle of some [ __ ] at a
house and 50 dudes showed up
for him
to help him
that's the feeling that i get out of
like
the squad that i have you know it's not
tied to like
what uh what i'm doing what they don't
ask me questions like hey man what are
you working on that's not that's not
what goes on in that room you know yeah
um and there's other people in that room
who dip and dabble in the arts and stuff
like that but there's also like
just regular cats you know um and it's a
great equalizer
it's a great equalizer it's a
it just keeps me in check it keeps me on
the ball you know it keeps me in
alignment
you know they ask questions like were
you honest all day
you know they ask questions like
what'd you do for somebody else today
you know
uh were you kind to all god's kids
were you kind to everybody today oh you
weren't tell me about it well i flipped
the dude off in traffic word why
you know oh well and then you know you
talk it out
not that you're trying to dwell in the
the toxicity but like you're trying to
get to you're trying to build an
awareness around how you move in this
life so that you can create like a bit
of distance from your reactions
i'm such a reactive person and and being
like
being a cat who like uh
i mean i'm not stanislavski i don't know
why people accredit me with this [ __ ]
that's your thing i was never that guy i
was far more
uh
into um
into a different craft you know i was
far more reactive and when you when you
when you work that way then it's very
difficult to like
navigate the world and not be that you
know i was very reactive in life which
is a lot of where this drama came from a
lot of this trauma and pain that i
perpetuated on people was so reactive
um so i'm developing a pause i'm
developing like the ability to shut the
[ __ ] up and not do anything
you know and it felt so masculine to not
do something it feels like a masculine
to not do something
and um for me there's nothing more
masculine than a mountain
tell me why just don't do much and it's
always there yeah yeah and you can't
move it yeah yeah yeah
and so like that's complicated
it's good it's got all kinds of [ __ ] on
yeah but it's also super simple that's
true too yeah i mean not to get too like
already farting with the [ __ ] but i like
the stability of a mountain i like the
simplicity of a mountain
i like the complexity of a mountain
there's different notes sure you know
different elevations yeah i'm not i'm
not interested in like a monotone naive
optimism either you know that's not what
i'm pitching it's not it doesn't make me
effective to tell a dude who's in the
middle of being on fire hey it's all
going to be okay um because it's not
some shit's not gonna be okay and
and then you gotta ask yourself why
that's happening
and god either is or he isn't you know
that's just it's very simple and so
even the negativity that befalls your
life or any kind of tragic [ __ ] that
happens in your life really is you're
being tapped
you know this is how god refines
and and so i'm blessed bro i'm blessed
for all the fuck-ups too i'm blessed
that that um
that i had a group of people around me
who when i was in triage mode could
really grab my arm and tie a tourniquet
and now i'm able to
to pay it forward and be a service to
other people and even show up here and
like look another man in the eye
just that was like a big hurdle to get
past when you're in the kind of shame
that i was in and you've been uh
defined a certain kind of way in the
public just to get to the place where
you could sit down and look another man
in the eye and speak honestly about
where you're at that's a big that's like
a testament to a lot of work that got
done 100
and really if that's all you get out of
doing the work then then then do the
work you know so and i keep going to
this god thing and i and and it's not
like they get out of jail free card for
me you know it's not like i'm trying to
say this stuff to to um
absolve myself of anything you know i
i'm i'm i'm trying to
be an advertisement for what this did in
my life it it changed my life
i was kicking it with these monks for
nine months and i for a while i just
thought like
santa ines
there's a monastery called the san
lorenzo novitia it's a monastery okay
franciscan monks and i was there for
living in my truck in the parking lot
for months until they brought me in and
wound up being like this nine month
journey with them
and
they laugh so much
you never think monks are
they just [ __ ] they're laughing all
the time they're laughing like
they're laughing a laugh that feels pure
it's not based on like this
cutting of anybody uh cutting anybody
out it's like can you give me an example
like somebody like like lets a fart out
or yeah
it's just like childish babies they've
been laughing about since they're little
kids bro it's like it's like they've
cultivated their innocence they're like
kids they're not but there's this
innocence to them
when they don't have to d they've taken
permanent vows of chastity obedience and
poverty
and when you cut that [ __ ] out of your
life it leaves you with this
a very a very
specific palette with which to paint
when when money isn't dictating any of
your decisions because you don't have a
bank account
when when
sexual relations and [ __ ] and that's
not clouding your brain infringing on
your ability to see [ __ ] if you're not
in charge of nothing
if you're completely obedient to
basically their commanding officer
they're the head of the head of
vocations then it puts you in this very
like
whimsical
wonder there's a lot of wonder it's like
they're they're they're in awe all the
time not like in a naive way you never
had see you've never seen people have
more fun at a barbecue kind of way the
kind of [ __ ] where like i remember one
time
there was there was a couple of monks
there you know they would go get
groceries people donate stuff to them
right they don't buy [ __ ] they live off
of the whatever somebody's some day is
gonna be edamame some days it's gonna be
gummy bears they're they're living off
of what they get right there's a beauty
tool they're happy with as [ __ ] with
everything no but i mean like is there
is there's no preference i'm a beans
like for real yeah yeah straight but but
is it but is the lima beans is that
disappointment they will freak some lime
beans it's not like they don't know what
they're doing
they're good with it they're going to
freak lima beans
and lima beans gonna be something you
want to have you know yeah yeah um
they're gonna freak it out whatever it
is they're gonna do go get to work
there's 20 dudes going to be in there
like chefing yeah like
uh yeah
some gummy bears you know we're about to
make this happen yeah it's going to pop
in here tonight yeah and uh they're
excited about it you know uh
they'll be walking up and down the
hallways like lima beans tonight you
know anyway so i remember driving behind
him and this is like early days this is
back when i had you know when abel first
reached out to me about doing this it
was all ego i was still early days of
sobriety it was like ooh back to hustle
wiggle room that's how it started for me
it's like oh you want me to do what with
who william defoe oh bro let me yeah oh
yeah forget all this sobriety talk
forget all this cleaning yeah i'm back
oh here we go bro back right it happened
so fast
and um now i'm in the mirror again i'm
doing my [ __ ] again just back to the old
me you know just getting to work you
know trying to find who this dude could
be and
and uh
and i'm expl i'm back in it like
full-blown did it diminish the shame the
shame that was on your shoulder did that
start yeah it went away it went away i
mean this is what work used to do for me
it was like oh you talk [ __ ] all you
want agent man but i'm like going to
work so like i don't care you know and
even now like
there's parts of me that are like well
yeah okay you can hate on me hate on me
all you want but i'm still talking to
this dude or doing that and you know my
head still i'm still yeah i'm a human
human being of course and you got to
navigate you got to see when it happens
you know right away when you said that
i'm in my head like ooh coppola yeah you
know like i want to like speak to like
who are you to this and
just constant it happens it's just a
constant
um process you got to be aware of
um
so yeah i remember driving behind them
to go pick up this stuff and this is
early days so i'm not even there for
spirituality i'm there for like where do
you put your hands what's it look like
when you do this i'm just like building
right i'm just building you know all
right what kind of you know like the the
that the vapid [ __ ] yeah what kind of
shoes you know yeah yeah just like oh
prayer life yeah okay boom yeah what
does that look like it just looks like a
dude sitting in a room okay cool but i'm
not going to actually get involved in
that process you know and so i'm driving
behind them they're going to pick up
these groceries
and i see this dude on the left turning
the dude on the right and he just starts
laughing
just ha ha ha
like the kind of light looks like a
cartoon like a cartoon laugh but it's
kind of silhouetted because i'm in the
back watching them drive
and
i remember thinking to myself like
i've experienced that a bit in my life i
remember being on fury with you and
laughing like that on the tank these are
like
the most incredible moments of my life
looking back now these moments where
you're laughing like that
and they laughed all the way to go get
the lima beans
and on the way back to the seminary they
laughed all the way back to the seminary
and i thought this was a one-off
and every time we would get in the car
and these dudes would get in the car it
was this silhouette of just outrageous
laughter
and
you know you ask him like
what are you laughing about man and the
dude's like don't know everything
everything sometimes i just look at the
dude and we'll just start laughing at
each other and it's it's um
it's
joy was the first
like
laughter was the first miracle it felt
like
i don't know that was the first
attractive thing about faith for me was
the laughter and the fact that these
monks aren't like docile
solemn all the time you know they cut
each other's hair they're in the gym
they're dudes but they also have a
principled life
and that became very attractive to me at
a certain point i've always been
attracted to guys like kevin vance i've
always been attracted to a marine to a
gangster to an extremist who's got who's
cultivated this kind of tribe around him
who it resembles some kind of weird
jumbled up idea of masculinity to me
these go-getters in life
because really what's sexy is the
commitment
the commitment to a lifestyle direction
is sexy
whether it be beau or kevin or whatever
you're committed to it it's a lifelong
thing it's not a tattoo there's no
removal this is forever right and so you
get around these monks and you feel
something like what you feel when you're
around kevin you feel something like
what you feel when you're around bo it's
sexy it's super appealing you're a part
of a group and they're they're knee-deep
in it they they are in love with what
they got going on and the hollywood [ __ ]
is secondary and you know i remember
telling them what was going on for me in
my life when i was there and they were
the first guys to say
um
things to me that sounded like there was
a route towards something salvific for
me like
like
it happened
um like this stuff also happened to a
man named saint augustine
and they started breaking down augustine
to me and who he was and started
explaining to me who saint francis was
and you come to find that most of these
stories of saints in the faith were
fuck-ups
full-blown fuck-ups they weren't perfect
people who did perfect [ __ ] their whole
lives and they wound up they were they
required me touched by god from the
beginning poop and gold like yeah it
wasn't that way yeah the requirement for
their sainthood was the [ __ ] up that
they'd been there they had to
they had to have experienced
real negative [ __ ] in their life
to be able to have this other thing this
salvation this
hero's journey they're explaining saints
to me it's like the hero's path you know
and i'm a writer i'm in my head you know
what is my hero's journey i'm always
asking myself well what and this is sort
of and i always thought it was going to
be through the craft that my hero's
journey was kid from the bottom came to
hollywood with no [ __ ] training and
now now i'm like you know working with
these people and this and i'm doing that
and that was my hero's journey and it
was so curt it was so blunt and lazy
and it wasn't like this other thing
that's available and so
you get around these dudes and you hear
about their path
and how these guys got there and you
start meeting dudes who like
professional tennis players you know got
lost on steroids you know drugged up got
completely wayward and then decided to
enter the order
and so these are dudes who know
something about competitive you know
competitive sports they know about like
ego
in the way that i do the only people
i've ever been able to
feel like i'm close to in terms of the
way that i deal with my craft is
athletes it's sports figures and you
find that a lot of sports figures are
deeply insecure people
because it's all based it because it's a
meritocracy and that's what i
irregardless of this is if this is how
the business works now i view the way i
view the business is it is a meritocracy
you know you you you get respect based
on what you can do and how hard you work
and sports is like that and that's a
shitty way to live
because everything that comes to you is
based on you and what you do
and if everything in your life surrounds
you and is centered on you
you become a [ __ ] uh a vapid
self-interested selfish self-centered
human being how could you not the world
is happening in front of you the default
setting already is that you're
completely self-absorbed but then when
you're involved in a meritocracy
like pete working for commission
basically when then then it's all about
your efforts your efforts dictate the
how your life is going to go and then
there's no room to have faith the guys
that couldn't make the team are you
worthless because you didn't make it
yeah not at all do you have a purpose
out there are you important but that not
at all is not a given it's not a
understood understood well i think it's
it
it is probably was and is
extraordinarily difficult for you
i had no value once they took the job
from me there was no value in me as a
human without this craft
i didn't have any reason to be alive
my whole life and you were super
untrusting of friendship bro like you
never you know what i mean like true
that's what like before i even met you
man i was like i'm gonna show that
[ __ ] what it's like to have a
friend he's like i'm gonna be his friend
and you it was always you know it was
always a resistance which made me
untrusting of love which made me entrust
a love in every version and capacity of
it and so
my relationship with my wife all the
friends that i had in my life they were
always like
less than they could be
and
even with guys like bo you know when bo
kept in contact with me through all this
you know
you know and other people as well but it
was guys like that who had messages of
depth and weight who could really speak
to the fact that like you'd been lower
that's right beau had been lower than me
beau was sitting down for a long time
now i'm not in prison for a bunch of
different reasons that have to do with
politics and
reality of race relations in america and
you know if this [ __ ] had happened to a
white woman and i was a black man this
would be a different story we wouldn't
be talking in the same kind of thing i'm
fully aware of the kind of privilege
with which i moved through the world
right and um
and so beau is able to like when we talk
about humility and getting right sized
you need certain dudes if you're a
person like me you need certain people
who've been there who've experienced
certain [ __ ] in their lives where they
can speak to what you're dealing with
because a therapist isn't going to speak
to it you know i'm not going to hear it
from you who studied carl young in
harvard for five years and really grew
up in thousand oaks and then you know
you you got injured when you played
football and then life just all worked
out like i'm not gonna hear it from you
it has to be from a guy who i know
has been there and also a guy who i know
has a real laugh
bo has real joy in his life
real joy it's not manufactured and it's
not it's also not tied to his finances
or his uh his ego
that dude is a service to his he's got a
he has a route towards being of service
to his
the hood his people the people around
him you know he's involved in in the
community and he's of service the whole
reason that [ __ ] started up was i was
piggybacking his knowledge of how to be
a service for my ego
slauson started with a conversation with
me and him
me trying to you know i was trying to
join a gang i was in a you know i was
hanging out with a bunch of harpies
members and was like
fully jumped in and was a part of a gang
and trying to talk to him about
[ __ ] he's looking at me like bro you
don't know [ __ ] you know you got a bunch
of tattoos and like okay right you got
jumped in the parking you don't know
anything about this [ __ ] you know and
and he was generous with me he could
have just wrote me off you know as a
person with no depth and no weight
because i hadn't experienced [ __ ] in my
life compared to him
now we speak more like
contemporaries because he knows how to
bend to hell in a real way
and he knows while we were talking i was
there yep
and
it i mean this is kind of part of being
a man it's like
you kind of gotta [ __ ] it all up a
little bit i think so i think part of
learning is dying
i think part of learning is you got to
die a little bit because what is
learning learning is me giving up on my
old [ __ ] my old ideas those ideas have
to die for me to be open to some new
[ __ ] and so me learning how to be a
better man i had to die a little bit and
when you kill [ __ ] inside of you man
there's a [ __ ] hole and you don't
know what to put in there right you just
gotta find the right food right you
gotta find the right food and i was
lucky to have like
some good dudes in my life at the time
when it hit for me to be able to fill it
with the right [ __ ] you know and and
that's only further it's the longer i've
been in the middle of it you know
getting in contact with
whatever spiritual path you find but
when you're around a bunch of dudes who
are really committed to that kind of
life
uh it rubs off on you if you're around
it long enough i just want to give you
one more opportunity if you wanted just
to speak about your your wife man and
just about what she means to you and and
um
you know her her path and her
relationship with all this i know she's
been a part of your life for a long time
just just if you if you're feeling it
just speak on her yeah well
uh
i'll never be able to speak on it i
don't i don't know nothing like this
relationship i never have in my life i
never had even my parents even my father
you know i never had what i got with her
which is
you know
to enter my life to be with me she had
to take a loss
she had to like eat [ __ ] to be with me
to be with me she had to to re-enter
being a part of my life she had to take
a hit
uh
in ways that i've spoken about before
and in other ways too probably you know
and uh
what i know love to be is selfless
loving action
and i've never known anything as loving
or as selflessly
active as what this woman did for me in
my life she showed up for me at a time
when i mean this is the first time i saw
her we had been a strange for like
years because of my jealousy she went
and did a movie with another actor and i
thought she was cheating on me so then i
cheated on another but it was just
[ __ ] messing all that we [ __ ] uh
little boy [ __ ] like nonsense and we
hadn't talked for two years
when all this [ __ ] hit
and
i wound up at this rehab right um in
utah
and they do something called family week
and every week
on a sunday everybody who's involved in
the program has their family show up on
these skype calls
and everybody will show up in the same
room
and
your mother your father your brother
your sister your wife your friends just
you and the people no it's you the whole
squad of you that are in this group
like twelve of us and mine's everyone's
family everyone's family pops up on the
screen
and
week one
no one shows up for me no one
they got the calls i know they got the
calls but no one showed up my mother my
father no one no one showed up
manager friends no one showed up
week two same thing
so i'm sitting in this room and even the
person who's like therapizing me
she's starting to feel like this
she's empathizing with where i'm at
everybody else in the room we gotta do
to like you know
this isn't just alcoholics and [ __ ] this
is like [ __ ] arsonists and like child
predators and all kind of wild people in
this group right and they got people
showing up for them and i don't have
nobody showing up for me
and
week two week three i'm there 90 days so
i'm there for
a a clip and
there comes a point where family weed
comes around i say to my therapist like
i'm not gonna go you know like i don't
want to subject myself to this [ __ ] like
i'm i'm on a path and you know let me
just stay here like i don't want to keep
reminding myself how [ __ ] my situation
is
and um
and she says no i think you should show
up this week
and i show up thinking all right my
mom's going to be on there you know my
mom will be on and
mia is on the screen
and
you know like
you don't deserve that kind of [ __ ] you
know you don't deserve that punish
like
like i don't deserve that kind of [ __ ]
you know i don't put i don't put her
through years and years of [ __ ]
nonsense bro just like
all right
and i don't have nothing to offer her
either you know what i mean i'm in the
middle of my [ __ ] you know i'm [ __ ]
like
i'm like
i'm like two months into this program
you know i don't even have nothing going
on i don't even have no i have nothing
nothing going on i'm making this list
she's at the top of the list but i
i'm not reaching out to her nothing like
that and uh
and yeah you were her voice like she's
like a [ __ ] angel you know i mean she
and
everybody does their [ __ ] and i'm
[ __ ] gone you know and so they let
her go first because i can't even
[ __ ] believe and they all know
because i had no family show up for me
and she just she a mutes and she's like
hi shia she's doing it's like
she's prepping a movie she ain't got no
[ __ ] time for this you know but she
found time and she said hi shia
and uh we just smiled we got nothing
else to say
but she saved my [ __ ] life dog like
it uh before the kid before the job
before [ __ ] before god before any
religion before any before laugh before
a laugh before a laugh
before bo before a phone before anything
was this woman's face and uh
the one no promises made what no long
conversation had been had nothing just
her presence the ministry of presence
sometimes that's all you need to offer a
person who's in a situation like that is
like
just to be present
and she was present for me at a time
when i didn't deserve to have nobody in
my life
especially her and i'm not trying to do
this [ __ ] because i right away my
head goes to like how's this being
viewed i'm such a [ __ ] this way good you
come on man yeah uh
she's a she's a she's a real one
she's a real one in that
and uh
i'll never be able to
i'll never be able to
it's the first time i really understood
love because i didn't have nothing to
give and i was sitting there thinking
like
well i don't have nothing
it's not sexy to be with me don't you
get it like
people out here accusing me of like
putting makeup on my genitals and like
shooting dogs and [ __ ]
you know
that's what i'm being accused of
and you're showing up for me like you're
you're going to be tied to this [ __ ]
i couldn't it didn't make no [ __ ]
sense
and love is irrational that way
you can't rationalize real love it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense and i
spent my whole life trying to
rationalize it like ah
you know this dude hits me up he's in my
corner because you know we [ __ ] with the
same crap you know i mean that's what he
he loves this thing that i got that i'm
like i'm g with this [ __ ] over here
that's why he loves me because he loves
that part of me that's g at this
you know and and then i would i would
write your love off like okay you love
me because i do this [ __ ]
and so many of my relationships were
basically like you love me because i'm
[ __ ] sensei over here in the dojo i'm
black belt right here so you love me
because of this and when they blow the
dojo up you're like i'm not g i'm not
sensei and nothing i got no i'm not a
fish i don't even have to [ __ ] do
nothing like i don't even know how to
camp i'm a [ __ ] little kid you know i
mean i know how to make a fire
and uh
yeah she gave me hope bro when i was
really like running on fumes
i wasn't running on empty but i was
running on fumes i had a sponsor in my
life who was kind of
he was saying yo be patient the [ __ ]
will show up miracles will show up
this was another miracle
bags packed is a miracle you know them
laughing in the car is a miracle my
wife's face on the skype call is a
miracle the [ __ ] starts to add up where
you know it it becomes this like
it creates faith
because you're not doing it
it wasn't some [ __ ] dope poem i sent
or some flowers i sent to put her on the
skype call and it wasn't good behavior
of being a man
it wasn't good sex that got my wife on
the skype call it wasn't like any of the
self-will [ __ ] that i used to validate
her being in my life like even my sex
life was like it was so performative
it was like well
if a woman didn't orgasm i would
question it you know like what does this
mean about me it was always about me i
never had like
like
like a real coupling it was always
performative and it was always like
this constant
validation trip if i i would try to look
for the same [ __ ] i got at work over
here in this relationship and the reason
i didn't like being friends with men is
it was constantly this comparison study
you know
this has been difficult too is to like
reach back out to people who are in my
corner then who are still in my corner
but are g's
it's hard to reach out to dudes like
that because you knew them at a certain
level you know another dude who really
showed up for me was cuddy
like he was the first friend that really
hit me back you know like
and he's a [ __ ] g dude is like his
life is on fire and it's hard to like
i've always known him at a certain kind
of equivalency
we've always been to be in a in a in
each other's lives as sort of like
you know
like i knew him at a level
and i'm not at that level
and sometimes it's difficult to like
to show up for the love
to show up for the love that people have
thrown at you
because you think you're you know you
think you are these twitter comments you
think you are this idea what you what
ah [ __ ] i gotta get out of this octave
because i sound like boohoo [ __ ]
come on being you bro yeah but i don't
want to be [ __ ] performative
it's difficult for a dude in my spot to
receive love
uh
because you you don't feel like you
deserve it
and so
uh
you wind up dipping on a lot of people
even when they're showing up for you and
then you got to have like real
conversations i had to really put it out
there to him like bro i don't feel
successful enough to be your friend
anymore
what a [ __ ] like crazy [ __ ] to write
but you gotta
you gotta air it out you're not stuck
there anymore no i wouldn't be able to
sit here with you if i was there right i
won't be able to sit here and talk to
you about this [ __ ] right and so it's
it's re so the the emotion right now
what this is almost
i'm looking back at it because i think
[ __ ] what a sorry case like what a sad
[ __ ] for real you know what
and that's who i was not even that not
even that long ago bro this is like two
months ago but i understand but the fact
that you that the fact that you were
there the fact that you've been there
that you treaded on that path
means you can actually talk to others
who are [ __ ] locked in and i should
and i do that's it man and and uh
yeah and and um that really is my
purpose in life now is to like
be able to express the reality of my
life that you could be where i just was
you know in some kind of sense memory
like remembering the text message
conversation i have with this man and
also know that
now we talk all the time
you know
now i don't need to be anything
i don't need to be a certainness or a
certain that to
have permission to have friends
or a wife
or
or anything like i
i deserve it
and that's a hard thing to
to say that you deserve love when on
paper no you don't
you know i mean listen bro like
for me there are a few things as
ugly as putting your hands on a woman
what else is what is there's nothing
worse i remember i used to come into a
all the time put my hand up like yeah i
just got in a fight with a cop i grew up
on eze this shit's sexy you know i mean
i used to put my hand like i just
flipped the car you know there's got to
fight with with this or that and there
was like this faux
it was like it was like i romanticized
that kind of [ __ ] when you come back in
and you raise your hand and you don't
even need to raise your hand because
dude's already read it your baggage
already showed up at the hotel before
you got there people know about you
there's nothing sexy about what i'm
dealing with
and that's what makes me useful
it's also why i go to strictly men's
meetings because you don't hear about
dudes talk about what we're talking
about at a mixed meeting
because very quickly once women are
involved i probably wouldn't be able to
talk like this with you if there was a
woman here because right away the the
little boy in me would start like
curating again you know what i mean and
and when i'm here with you i can forget
about that also and all this [ __ ] it
takes a certain kind of dude to be able
to open a person up like this and be
receptive of it and also like show up
and look the dragon in the eye knowing
that there's purpose yeah like i'm
purpose driven here i'm willing to
eviscerate myself and emasculate myself
and like
because i know that there's this grander
purpose than like me trying to 100 yeah
so so the reason i go to strictly men's
meetings is because you get people dudes
get vulnerable about the ugly [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that dudes don't want to talk about
and
the reason the show is important
is cause you kind of serve the same
purpose that those things on a
on a bigger scale
in a less specified sense for a lot of
dudes that don't have a masculinity
ceremony there's no puberty ceremony in
culture right
what when do you come in as an american
man when do you become a man when you
get a driver's license like what do we
do you 16 we give you a driver's license
okay well like you get a job like when
do you become a man you become a man
when you become responsible for other
people
and part of that is taking
accountability
and so like i i'm very new to this being
a man thing
and i'm still not there
and i'm on a path
but i didn't have no like
i grew up on a
in a culture
that told me going to war made you a man
going to prison and coming back coming
back makes you a man um
making a million dollars makes you a man
you know
and and it doesn't and you don't know it
till you didn't done all these things
and realized damn i'm still a little
[ __ ] boy or been around people who've
been there a bunch of times you know i
don't know nothing about being at war
like kevin but i know a bunch of
soldiers that come back and are still
[ __ ] little boys can't wait to get
back out i know so many dudes can't wait
to get back out you know guys that we
know uh
you know
warriors uh but even warriors don't make
that don't make you a man that's right
you know
also my definition of warrior has
changed me too you know i didn't really
know what that meant and really it's
about bringing others back
and
that's my whole [ __ ] mission dog
really is just like
dudes who've been where i've been or
something similar just know
it gets better
it does like
it don't make no sense
it doesn't make no sense it's irrational
it doesn't make any sense on paper that
i could have joy in abundance in my life
that i could feel
any kind of joy in my life after being
what i've been
it doesn't make this unclear it's not no
you've got no mind
yeah and also you got to get the [ __ ]
out of the way and that's that's where
the work really really is it's like
getting out the way
and allowing
this bigger thing to work in your life
because the bigger thing is working in
your life whether you know it or not and
you're either going to let go
willingly or you're going to get dragged
but either way you're going to be
humbled in this life
and
there's nothing you can do about it
how do you feel about the craft going
forward is that are you are you i know
you talked about the experience you just
had and aligned yourself and it served
you and served your mission and informed
your mission sure but but i
you also recognize that there's real
trappings you also recognize that
there's you say trappiness trappings
happiness is a good word for it yeah
trappiness but yeah the same [ __ ]
trappings doug you know what i mean
there's you you go down that path and
those voices
how do you feel what are you looking for
what's your interest do you have a plan
do you have desires do you have like
like so tell me so like what's your
relationship to it now i'm not just
saying this because it sounds good like
my
i'm i'm my professional good guy like
all i care about is my purpose i don't
you know i don't really think about
craft much when it pops up
[Music]
and really the only guys that can work
with a guy like me are dudes at a
certain level
because they're going to have to talk to
a marketing department about why they
just hired an atomic bomb to come work
on their movie you know
and and and the only dudes who can
really make that kind of [ __ ] happen are
guys who are very far and few between
right
but i'm also not in this jobbing mode
you know i mean like
i was talking about do the other day
like
something really sexy about working at
home depot
you know my head goes there before it
goes to like let me go work on some
movie where i'm playing a romanian
vampire lawyer you know i mean you think
you could work at home depot yeah you
think you have this thousand percent but
you think you understand the inventory
of homes i spend so much time in home
depot
yeah that's a church for me yeah home
depot are you building a lot are you
working with yeah i'm in home depot all
the time okay so you feel like i love
home depot what what's another job you
feel like you you you could do that that
would both serve you and your mission
you feel like you'd be good at oh just
any kind of like regular [ __ ] like
regular like
do you think you could work in the
kitchen
no no because you're not good you know
well that's another kind of this that
takes this okay that's another kind of
crafty job where like you know the
impetus is on your the the poetry of you
right right then i'm [ __ ] lost again
right i'm talking about something that
doesn't where there where the poetry of
me doesn't matter one [ __ ] iota right
i need something like i'm looking at
jobs that that don't
cultivate your poetry and your
uniqueness looking for jobs that like
that keep me humble
and i think
working at home depot
is one home depot is full of
possibilities so in the back of your
mind there's not something
that's yearning i mean i'm sure the
voice is there that's saying i got i got
stories to tell i got to get out there i
got it no it's going oh no yeah it's
gone it's going it's going or it's just
quiet
i don't wake up and think about what
acting i'm gonna do right no that
doesn't uh
take any space in my life
um i don't have an agent i don't have
like i don't live that [ __ ] i have dudes
i'm around and i watch them do the [ __ ]
i don't do that
um
uh
both because i i've been my life is
structured in such a way where the
universe has has given me that gift
that's where i'm at right now i need you
to not be interested in me i need that
route to not be open to me for me to get
where i need to be for sure because if
it is for sure buddy boy for sure you
know i'm i'm gonna go is there any way
that you feel like you can use your
but that's also not to say that there
aren't opportunities where you can't say
no you know when coppola calls you when
when when abel ferreira calls you these
are dudes i looked up to before i was a
heretic right you know i mean i always
bad lieutenant for me top ten
you know uh the conversation top ten
this [ __ ] it's like when the top tens
call you
then then it's like don't deny god
either right and so
i i was blessed to work with abel and
had an incredible uh experience working
with him and made a lifelong friend in
him and he had the
clout and the
was insane enough
and was searching for something so
specific that he thought i was the right
guy for the job
uh i have something to offer for a very
specific kind of guy in a very specific
kind of role it happened to work there
um it also had intrinsic value attached
to it yeah and so that you know that you
learned by doing it you didn't know
going in
as it is i went in there on a let me get
back to my hustle mission you know abel
ferreira william defoe oh [ __ ] i'm back
on
i can i can read the deadline articles
now you know i mean like this is where
my
instantly
and so
uh
more humility had to happen through the
process you know and and it has to
happen on a day-to-day basis
you know i'm a
movie got into venice it's in
competition boy right away my [ __ ]
head could do all talk all kind of [ __ ]
and make me feel like oh you know what
you're back on dawg you know
and and and i i spend a lot of time in
prayer like why why why why do you got
us going there
you know
uh why have you made it
accessible to me
and not to other people why have you
provided me wiggle room it is my
responsibility to not make it that yeah
yeah and and what what kind of lesson am
i supposed to be learning here not just
not just in how to navigate the stuff
away from set but how do i navigate on
set relations do you want me to work
different
this is why my work indifferent happened
it was like
because my main priority was my good guy
and my way of working was
not about that at all my way of working
was animal it was totally
instinct driven
uh
magic cultivating i couldn't even put my
finger i don't have a process
you at least have a pr i don't have no
process my process is
i don't even know what it is i don't
know what i do
which is another
problem but um
this time it was because i was playing a
a priest a monk and i was surrounded by
non-actors it was no other actors there
was only monks around me you have no
there's no acting going on it's you're
going to show up in the morning and pray
with us
and you're going to have to learn latin
prayer you're going to have to do this
you can't act this you can't be over
here on your cell phone and jump over
here and be running mass it's not going
to work so
it forced me to
and there's a certain amount of humility
that comes with being a priest
and a certain amount of suffering that
you ask for you know a priest is a
masochist
it's the most masochistic thing in the
world to want to be a priest
because what are you actually doing it's
the ultimate performance when you go up
and run mass you're performing
the death of christ
you're not just telling the tale you are
embodying
the the
the uh
the journey to the mount you are
performing it and the good ones really
go there i happen to be playing a dude
who and this is why the job worked for
me
invited a certain amount of destruction
into his life
he invited a certain amount of pain and
he painted with his pain
he felt pio specifically felt that
his mass was a was a massive tears and
so he would cultivate all this pain
he was nourishing and cultivating and
watering his pain on a day-to-day basis
because he felt his purpose was to
suffer for others and i was there for a
minute i remember talking to you about
like what this job is
you know your job is to show up and
bleed out
that's how we used to talk about this
what is the job show up and die in front
of the camera you better you know leave
it all on the field that's how i used to
talk about my craft was i am a vessel
for suffering
what i do best is i suffer in front of a
camera
and
so you're playing this guy you have this
certain way of working and yet it's like
the most
it's the most
loving calm
collaborative
lack of control in a performance i've
ever had the performance isn't something
i made it happened to me
you know we would do takes and right
before the take i'd get nervous and i'd
look over to
this dude named brother alex
and i never used to do this
i used to play like music on loudspeaker
you know i used to be such like a
manager you know yeah but you got to
play this song on this i'm going to go
jump in the corner and i'm going to
you've seen how i get down like it's so
managed
i'm not going to show up on set until
i'm not going to rehearse i'm going to
do this
this guy's got to be here and you got to
do this don't look at me and you're
getting in my way you're the enemy yeah
yeah get away from me yeah i don't need
you here you know
and um
this time it was like i was leaning on
dudes who weren't weren't actors you
know and they would look at me and they
don't have the answers either and
sometimes it's not that sometimes when
you're entering a mass of tears and
you're playing
one of the most important figures in all
the catholicism the pressure is heavy
the pressure's enormous you're in italy
you're staying at the seminary he grew
up in he is
he is considered like the most important
other than christ in italy he is the
most important catholic he's more
important than saint francis
he is they paint him on walls he's so
when you tell people you're playing p.o
right away
you can't live up to it it's just
impossible you're never going to get it
and and really it's like playing bob
dylan if you're going to play bob dylan
you better learn how to play some songs
if you're going to play p.o you need how
to know how to run a mass
and so there's a lot of pressure in a
mass and so 11 months of prep
went to this one moment where you're
getting ready to run this mass and old
me would have been so managed
old me would have been so
nitpicky and so controlling and this got
to be there and that's got to be here
and really like i showed up on set it
was the easiest and probably the best
work of my life
i showed up on set i looked at this man
i told him i loved him he told me he
loved me and then you're off and running
and i had never had that as a motivator
when i told you like what motivated my
life before all this happened to me
wasn't love it wasn't
good will towards my fellows
the idea that that was that somebody's
life would be motivated by that felt
cheesy and like naive
you know like not in this dog-eat-dog
environment no way
it's actually the most powerful 100 yeah
i never worked from that place i never
used that well
and i didn't know that well was full
either
uh and then you turn to that well and
that world is full and the work is
better and it's almost like a part of
you dies a little bit it's like we talk
you you learn to
to move a different way but if you told
me that when we were on fury i'd have
told you you kick rocks bro what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you know no
way yeah uh and maybe that was what you
were trying to tell me you know maybe
maybe i just wasn't open to the message
i remember top
i remember brad turning to me one time
in a scene
and this is brad right the [ __ ] am i a
brad brad no matter what you look at you
know there's no way you can write the
man off as a craftsman as a [ __ ]
adonis as a father as an all-around g
the dude is
thorough
and i remember being on set with him
and him turning to me after a scene and
saying man
what do i do
and my [ __ ] ass
got lost i was intoxicated brad pitt
just asked me what to do i didn't even
hear what the question was
my response wasn't even it didn't come
from no honest place all i heard was
you're amazing yeah
wow i didn't see the genius of his
humility i didn't see the beauty in his
love wow i didn't see it i didn't see
this selfless act he was actually
bigging me up
and using his take to do it
he knew i was next he knew they were
going to turn this camera around and i
was going to have to go after him
because no matter how you structure it
when you're the star of a movie you go
first usually
and he was going first and he used his
last take
he threw it away just so he could big me
up because he knew the camera was
turning around and all i heard was
you're [ __ ] amazing dog give me
advice
and that [ __ ] me up for a while i just
wasn't ready to hear or see what he was
actually doing which was
coming from this place of humility and
love and like self
he was like
self um i don't know what the word is
it's not emolliating but he he kind of
like
he leveled himself to like big me up and
i never moved like that or knew anything
about that in life or in craft yeah but
i've been around dudes who did it i just
couldn't see it you know i looked up to
like the
the rah-rah gorillas i was around you
know
part of me really appreciated working
with you because i thought here's
another rah-rah gorilla i'm around
but yours has you have an adaptation
that i didn't actually couldn't see at
the time you know because you
loved us all of us you know i remember
me and penny were about to get in a fist
fight in london yeah i remember yeah and
you showed up for us and that fight went
away
and you didn't have to do that you know
and and
it's not always like tough guy either i
remember like
sitting in the grass with you and you
being like hey let's run these scenes
uh and that's like sitting in the grass
like on some dead poets society [ __ ] i
mean sitting in the grass just like
reading to each other
with apples and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but yeah i i um
some of the stuff i now i see now was
around me already and i just wasn't open
to it
um
even the things like
hardy was always very brotherly with me
very luck he's another dude who in the
midst of all this [ __ ] i had to make
amends to him
i had to make amends to him because um
you know i mouthed i did a press tour
where i mouthed off about how me and him
got in a fist fight and da da and like
on my rah-rah let me define myself by
using this other man who's respected in
the world and let me minimize him to big
myself up kind of [ __ ] like
and i had to make amends to him he was
on my list
and uh
and when i hit him uh
you know the response also because he's
got principles in his life you know the
the response wasn't even a conversation
it was not even a
it was um
i love you you don't owe me no amends
you know but thanks sometimes it is just
that simple but the fact that i'm i'm
showing up for it and i'm i'm taking
stock in my life and i'm
i'm defining that vague tension that
existed between me and other people
is how i got to move so that i don't
have this monologue in my head that
tells me i'm a piece of [ __ ] in order to
get rid of that monologue i gotta show
up and i gotta clean it up
that's really what i'm doing now so you
ask me if i think about
acting much i got bigger fish to fry
right now
that's where i'm at
i know not much i know i love you i know
i'm blessed today i know i got work to
do and i know that it's all gonna be
okay in the end and if it's not okay
it's not the end
i like watching from afar
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's jon
bam bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team i just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that i bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something i'm i'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further we're
going to introduce a patreon community
and basically what that means is if you
become part of this community look i
already bored bam bam if you want to
become a part of this community you're
going to be able to hear episodes early
and all that ad free and all that good
stuff but there's all this behind the
scenes footage all this stuff that we've
shot
that really brings you into the folks
that we've had on the show really brings
you into their world you're going to be
able to do live chats with me and the
folks that i bring on the show to talk
about their world talk about the issues
that they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and um
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll